[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARY LIZ MCCURDY: So
let's get started.
Again, we have groups
from all over Google.
And Jilian flew up
from LA for the day.
And so for those that
don't know her, or know her
from one of these
different settings--
you might know her from "The
Biggest Loser," or from one
of her eight "New York
Times" bestselling books,
or from her online fitness
platform called FitFusion,
or from her podcasts, or
her DVDs, or most recently,
her app, which launched
on Google Play.
Woo-woo.
All very excited about that.
She's here to talk to
us today about some
of her lessons learned, her
career journey, and then,
some of her health and fitness
insights on the industry
and where everything is headed.
So with that, I'm going to
kick it over to Jillian.
JILLIAN MICHAELS: Well, thank
you so much for having me.
Super excited to be here.
It's like Oz, but
the wizard is real.
So it's a [INAUDIBLE].
Anyway, yeah, if there is
anything that I can share,
or inform you with, or
answer questions-- obviously,
about health and fitness--
[INAUDIBLE] about
what you guys do.
And mad respect.
MARY LIZ MCCURDY:
There's so much.
JILLIAN MICHAELS: I'm
just excited to spend
some time with you.
MARY LIZ MCCURDY: Great.
So let's just get started
about the path you took.
How do you go about getting
100 million followers
and transforming a
fitness industry?
JILLIAN MICHAELS: In my early
20s, I made great money,
and life was a party.
And then I turned about 24.
And I was friends with people
in the entertainment industry
who were much older than me.
And it was like,
you need a real job.
You need to be responsible.
I was getting pressure from my
mom, who was worried about me.
What are you going
to do with your life?
You can't do this at 30, or 43--
which, you can, actually.
So anyway, I got a desk job
in the entertainment industry.
And I worked my way
into a talent agency
called International Creative
Management, which was one
of the big five at the time.
And I hated it.
But I mean, I guess you're
supposed to hate work.
I thought that's what you do.
You hate work, and
that's just part of life.
So to make a very long story
short, a bad day for your ego
is a great day for your soul.
And I managed to
get myself fired,
because I just could
not keep myself
from telling this one guy
how much of an asshole
I thought he was.
[LAUGHTER]
Anyway, not only
was I fired, I was
blackballed from working again.
Because he happened to
be a very powerful agent.
And I didn't know what
I was going to do.
I'm now 27.
And I was like, what the
hell am I going to do?
I had bills to pay.
So I fell back into
personal training,
because I had to pay bills.
And ironically, a
lot of the people
that I worked with at ICM
were coming to work with me.
I was working at
a sports medicine
facility helping to rehab
patients who were injured.
And they would come in, and
it was so embarrassing, right?
Here I am getting,
like, ice packs,
and I had been a junior agent.
And to make a long story
short, I get a call one day
from somebody I'd been
working with for a while,
crying because she'd felt her
hipbone for the first time
in eight years.
And in that moment, I
was like, all right,
somehow I got so far off-pieced.
Like, this is clearly
what I am good at.
This is clearly what
I'm meant to do.
It's clearly what I'm passionate
about and what I love doing.
How am I going to make
a business doing this,
and not just like, you
know, train one person,
make 50 bucks?
Because I didn't see that being
sustainable as I got older.
And that's where the
desire came was, first,
appreciating that you
can make a living at what
you're passionate about.
And I think so many people
believe that you can't,
which is just not the truth.
In fact, that's where you will
find affluence and abundance
is if you're doing what you
love and what you're good at.
So over the years, I began
studying other people who
had built brands, not
necessarily in fitness, and how
they did it, and what
platforms they utilized,
and what their career
trajectory was.
And to a certain extent,
some of that's a great idea,
and some of it isn't.
I definitely studied
the landscape.
I was very passionate
about what I do.
You need those two things-- an
understanding of the landscape,
to be passionate
about what you do--
to learn from your
failures and your mistakes.
But you also need-- man,
you need to be flexible,
and you need to pivot.
And I think that's how we built
such a big audience globally
was being able to pivot,
change course, move on, not cry
over spilled milk, not
throw good money after bad,
and be authentic with our
message throughout all of it
no matter what the platform
or the trend for people
to consume content.
Sorry, that was a
really long answer.
Jesus, OK.
MARY LIZ MCCURDY:
That was great.
JILLIAN MICHAELS: OK.
MARY LIZ MCCURDY:
So can you talk--
I think most of us
think about-- when
we think about Jillian Michaels,
we think about fitness.
But we know-- or I know, from
reading some of your books,
and from getting to know you
better, how much more you
are than that, an
entrepreneur, which
we'll talk a little bit about,
a philanthropist, author, and so
on.
So can you talk about
expanding beyond,
you know, what you were
originally known for,
and how that's
helped define your--
and define your own
personal brand and impact?
JILLIAN MICHAELS: Sure.
It's interesting, because a
lot of times people will ask,
especially peers,
when I speak to peers,
they're like, well, why you?
You're not a tremendous athlete.
You're-- you don't
have, you know,
your advanced degree
in kinesiology.
And, I mean, I do
study the science,
but they've got a
really good point;
there are fantastic fitness
trainers out there, so why me?
And if I was to
look at it, there
were definitely some
of those outlier
elements of time and place.
But I am a person that
doesn't actually love fitness.
I love what it does in my life.
I love that I fit into my
favorite pair of jeans.
I love that, you
know, I can spar
with my five-year-old and
my seven-year-old for hours.
But when I'm at the gym, I'm
not like, oh, fuck, I love this.
I feel slightly nauseous,
I'm really sweaty.
My quads are shaking.
I am in heaven.
Not ever.
That never happens.
So, for me, fitness
has always been
about building a better
life utilizing health
as the platform your
life is on top of,
and utilizing fitness
as an entry point
to rebuild someone's
self-worth and self-esteem.
Because when you're
strong physically,
it transcends into the
other facets of your life.
And I learned this
when I was very young,
as a bullied kid in junior high,
when I got into martial arts.
And so it's always been about
empowering people, not about
lunges.
And I think that's
transcended to my audience,
because they're like,
well, that's relateable;
I don't really love
the gym either.
And some people do.
You know, Bob Harper
loves the gym.
I call him the
consummate weirdo.
But, for me, I like
what it provides me.
And I think that's what's been
transcendent about our brand,
is the bigger picture.
MARY LIZ MCCURDY: Got it.
Awesome.
And most recently,
you've expanded
into multiple other territories.
We were meeting earlier
about Empowered Media,
and you've made a ton of
really interesting investments.
We also we're talking a
little bit about the research
that you're very excited
about on longevity.
So what's been getting you
out of bed most recently?
There's a lot going on upstairs.
JILLIAN MICHAELS:
My five-year-old.
Fucker.
Every morning--
MARY LIZ MCCURDY:
Like literally.
JILLIAN MICHAELS: --at 6
AM, literally, wha-mom.
I'm like, oh God.
I mean, but in truth,
I do think, you know,
I'm lucky to have great
friends and great family,
and that gets me out of bed.
And I'm unlucky
to love what I do.
You know, when it comes
to work, what's getting me
out of bed nowadays, I like--
the Jillian Michaels brand,
you know, it's-- for me,
it's a snooze fest, which I--
I mean, I love
the app, because I
can like-- it's
the closest thing I
can do to personal training.
But I'm not super
interested in my brand.
Like, I've done my brand,
and we know Jillian Michaels.
Got it.
So the question is how
do we use platforms
that have been created with
the Jillian Michaels brand
to grow other brands?
It could be a Better4U water,
an organic nitro cold brew,
an online healthy market that
is creating accessibility
and affordability, like Thrive,
for people in food deserts.
We're looking to
invest strategically
in Better4U options that
make health, happiness,
and wellness more affordable
and more accessible.
And-- and that's the kind
of stuff that excites me now
is growing those
kinds of companies.
And I think that's what's going
to change the face of wellness,
are places like Thrive
Market or younger generations
that speak to Z, you know,
not just the millennials,
And what is the message
that they're conveying?
And how can you help
give them a voice
and stand out amongst the noise?
MARY LIZ MCCURDY: Can
you talk about how
we should navigate things like
gluten-free versus ketogenic
versus paleo versus eating
for your blood type,
and, most recently,
eating for your DNA?
How do you know--
I mean, there's navigating
all of those different fad
diets, but then also eating
what's best-- finding out
what the best one is for you.
JILLIAN MICHAELS: Yeah.
MARY LIZ MCCURDY: How should
we go about doing that?
JILLIAN MICHAELS: Well, blood
type and DNA, one day blood
type no, DNA yes, and we're
about 25 years away from that.
Although we were 25 years
away from it 10 years ago.
Neutrogenomics.
So, you know, hopefully we
will understand, like, wow,
green tea turns off the breast
cancer gene in me but not you,
but you can have turmeric and
it will turn off ovarian cancer.
That will be the future.
And, you know, hopefully
we'll get there in a way
that all of us will be
able to benefit from it,
but we're not there now.
There are two universal
rules when it comes to food.
Calories are units of energy.
You-- anyone-- it's become
so trendy to be like,
I don't care what I weigh, and
I'm not getting on the scale.
That's bullshit.
It might be trendy,
but the scale
lets you know when you're on
track and when you're off.
It's a compass.
That's it.
If you're trying to lose weight
or maintain a healthy weight,
the scale will tell
you, hey, you've
got to make some changes,
or you're doing just fine.
That's it.
It's a barometer.
That's all that it is.
And calories are
units of energy.
So if you consume
more units of energy
than you're burning in a day,
you will store it as fat.
Fat is stored energy.
Fat does other things, but
that's what it is, right?
It's stored energy.
So I don't care
how healthy it may
be, we evolved, over
thousands of years,
to store fat for periods of
famine that were seasonal.
And we did not have Red #40
3,000, 4,000, 10,000 years ago.
So yes, you can eat too
much avocado or too much
cashews or too many
things and gain weight.
So, if you don't overeat,
you will not gain weight.
Then we get into food quantity--
or sorry, food quality, which
is what I just talked about.
And I don't care if
you're paleo or vegan,
nobody should be eating
hydrogenated fats.
Nobody should be
eating pesticides.
Nobody should be eating
growth hormones, and so on.
Two universal rules.
When I look at the rest of the
diets today, they really are--
I look at them like a religion.
We were talking
about it's choice.
I'm Buddhist.
Awesome.
Great.
I'm paleo.
Fantastic.
I'm vegan.
Wonderful.
So what I would simply say is
that if you choose a diet--
and generally, they're
macronutrient ratios,
if you think about it.
So if you're choosing a diet
to be vegan, vegetarian,
pescatarian,
omnivore, paleo, there
are certain pitfalls
with every diet.
As long as you're aware of
them and you're not overeating,
and you're not eating
poor quality food,
you'll be fine across the board.
So with paleo, make sure
you're getting enough fiber
and phytonutrients.
Make sure the meat
you're eating is organic.
I mean, we can get into the
environmental aspects of that,
but that's not really
the conversation.
If you're vegan,
and you're a woman--
men do much better on vegan
diets, because they don't--
how do you say--
MARY LIZ MCCURDY: Menstruate?
JILLIAN MICHAELS:
Thanks for that.
That.
Appreciate you.
I'm like a five-year-old
with shit like that.
I'm like, you know,
that thing that happens.
Right.
So men do much better on vegan
diets, believe it or not,
because they actually
have too much iron.
But we lose iron every month,
so we're more-- females
are more prone to anemia.
As long as you're
getting B12, a B12 shot,
and good sources of iron in
your diet, you'll be fine.
And if there are allergies,
like gluten allergies, then,
of course, you'll know what
your sensitivities are,
if you're lactose
intolerant, and then you'll
just avoid those things.
When it comes to
fine-tuning macronutrients,
I would simply say
listen to your body.
And this is where,
because people do
convert food into glucose
at faster or slower paces--
I wrote a book about
it many years ago,
and it was based on--
it's called oxidizer types.
So, the way you can tell, quite
honestly, is if you eat a meal
and it's predominately fat and
protein, and you feel superb,
then you likely break
down your food very quick,
because those things
break down very slowly.
Now, if you eat whole grain
toast and a little bit of fruit
spread on top, and
you're like, oh my God,
I'm exhausted, same thing.
So that's a person
that breaks down food
more quickly, in
which case, if you
eat things that break
down more quickly,
you're going to spike and crash.
Whereas, conversely, if you
break things down more slowly,
and you eat a ton
of fat and protein
and you feel like you've got a
weight sitting in your stomach
and you feel lethargic,
you'll do better
with more complex carbohydrates.
So that's where I would just
say listen to your body.
And the whole idea is really
how much energy do you have?
That's what will tell you.
And how long do
you feel satiated?
So, if you feel satiated
for three to four hours
and you feel like you can keep
going without eating again,
you've stabilized
your blood sugar
and you've hit that right ratio.
And a great place to
start is just be balanced.
South-- that's why
South Beach did so well.
It's 30, 30, 40.
Start there.
And if you feel great,
don't fuck with it.
If you don't, tweak
it a little bit
and see what gives
you more energy.
MARY LIZ MCCURDY: Mm-hmm.
Awesome.
So going back to the--
super helpful hearing a little
bit about the navigating diet
trends, one thing that's come
up recently in the press,
or maybe, you know,
you've seen this
in the past couple of
years, is New York Times'
deep dives on the role genetics
is playing on your metabolism.
And they've done some
interesting work,
like looking at the
Biggest Loser contestants
before and after.
JILLIAN MICHAELS: That's an
interesting conversation.
MARY LIZ MCCURDY: Yeah.
So I would love to hear
about your thoughts on,
you know, is it
nature or nurture?
Are we-- is it like baby,
I was born this way, or--
JILLIAN MICHAELS: Right.
MARY LIZ MCCURDY:
--is there actually
something we can do about it?
JILLIAN MICHAELS: OK.
Well, we'll get to "Biggest
Loser" in a minute.
First, let's discuss genetics.
Your genetics are as
unique on the inside
as they are on the
outside, right,
and for evolutionary purposes.
With that said, how you
respond to certain foods,
right, we were talking
about-- will be
different for differing people.
Some people are
lactose intolerant.
Some have gluten sensitivities.
Some people, as we
look at micronutrients,
some people will respond
to them in positive ways,
and some people it
won't do anything for.
But if you're looking at
weight, everybody can be fit.
Now, are you-- is
everybody going
to be a size zero
with, you know,
this percentage of body fat?
No.
Right?
That-- that's going to
involve your unique genetics.
Can anybody be fit and healthy?
Yes.
Is it easier for
some than others?
Yes.
I mean, if I look at
food, I will gain weight.
I was an overweight kid.
I mean, I cannot play
those kinds of games.
I just can't.
It's not-- like, you know,
my partner can eat anything
she wants, and is
still like, ugh,
I'm just trying to put
on five more pounds.
You know, I mean, and
that's-- and that's genetics.
But are we both fit and healthy?
Yes.
So, you can dramatically affect
the expression of your genetics
for better or worse.
So nutrigenomics, how does
food express your genetics,
epigenetics.
How's your environment
expressing--
facilitating the expression
of your genetics?
So, we are all
empowered, for better
and for worse, which brings
me to "Biggest Loser."
And it's kind of interesting.
So, one of those
contestants is a girl
named Shay, who is one of the
biggest contestants we'd ever
had on the show.
She's-- was over 500 pounds, and
she's still a friend of mine.
And, you know, they
put the weight back on.
And if they don't
ask for help, I
don't give unsolicited advice.
So I was like,
whatever, we're friends,
I'm not going to say
a word unless she
talks to me about it.
This is also a woman-- and a lot
of those people on that show,
you have to understand--
people watched it,
and it was a TV show,
but, for me, it was a
life-or-death intervention
on a ticking clock.
And you're dealing with trauma.
Tremendous trauma.
People don't get to 400, 500
pounds without deep trauma.
It's not because
they like pizza.
It's not.
I love pizza; I'm
not 500 pounds.
So, this is a
woman whose parents
were drug addicts, who was
in and out of the foster care
system.
So the study comes
out, and she's
like, I'm just curious
what you think?
I saw you said it was bullshit.
I'm like, you know I
think it's bullshit, Shay.
And she's like, why?
And I was like,
tell me right now,
are you eating 2000
calories a day?
No.
Are you moving your body
for four half hours a week?
No.
I was like, try that
and get back to me.
She lost 85 pounds,
again, in six months,
eating 2000 calories a day and
walking four half hours a week.
Got diagnosed with
thyroid cancer.
Just got it out, and she's-- we
don't even know if she's cancer
free yet, so that was kind
of a bump in the road.
But she's now maintained.
So she's like 425 again.
So it's like the minute we put
her back on 2000 calories a day
and walking four
half hours a week,
85 pounds falls off of her.
This is-- you know, and have
to understand the psychology.
There's a lot of shame that
goes on, so it's like, no,
the show did it.
And when they were on the show,
it was, mommy and daddy did it.
And when-- what you really
need in that scenario
is a therapist, because when
you're eating like that,
there's much deeper
stuff going on.
And people don't eat
dangerously or engage
in destructive behaviors because
they're weak or they're stupid
or they're lazy.
It's affording them something.
And it's affording them
something very significant.
And at one time or another,
that destructive habit
meant their
psychological survival.
So whether it was a
connection to a loved one,
or control, or
protection, you won't know
until you deal with the person.
But, to give that up is
way deeper than anything
we can comprehend
on the surface.
And that's-- that's what
that animal's really about.
MARY LIZ MCCURDY: Got it.
JILLIAN MICHAELS: It's
not about food at all.
MARY LIZ MCCURDY: Yeah.
JILLIAN MICHAELS: Well,
it is, but not literally.
MARY LIZ MCCURDY: Mm-hmm.
That's a helpful insight.
So, switching
gears a little bit,
we talked about
where you've been
and what you've been
doing most recently.
Can you share-- or
make a prediction
on where this whole
fitness industry is headed?
JILLIAN MICHAELS:
[EXHALES] God, there's
some things I see that
really distress me.
And then there's
some things I see
that I'm really hopeful about.
You know, I love the
integration of technology,
because information
is power, right?
And I always tell people, if
you have the right information,
you can make choices
that are going
to yield powerful results.
We get so confused thinking
that action and intention are
going to bring results.
But, in truth, if you
take misinformed action,
you'll have disaster.
But if you take informed, very
deliberate, specific actions,
and you make informed
choices, you're
going to get, most of the time,
really positive and powerful
outcomes.
So I love that
technology is giving us
this kind of information
now, so we can see, like, OK,
you know, you're not
working out hard enough.
Your heart rate's here.
Your burn was only
here; it should be here.
And then-- you know.
You can tell when people
have more, oh, I'm dying.
Yeah, your heart rate's
at 75; you're not dying.
You know, just various--
how far they walked, how
much they've done, like,
that stuff's exciting.
You know, how much they slept.
How much they had deep sleep.
How much hydration
they have, and so on.
The part that is distressing
for me-- and I, honest to God,
cannot tell if I'm
just really old now--
but is that, you turn,
you turn on Instagram--
and some of it I love.
You know, there are
some trainers on there
that I just love, and
I constantly, like,
friend and dialogue
with, and think
are great, and
watch them evolve,
and would like to put them on
FitFusion, and what have you.
And then, like, last
night I was watching
this one woman who was--
because it makes
suggestions, you know,
and she's working out
with a chair in her room,
so I'm watching it,
and I'm like, OK.
And the next thing I know,
it, like, turns into porn,
and there's a camera,
and she's like--
and I just-- that part
I'm like, ugh, God.
Like, as a woman in
general, I'm like, why?
And I-- I don't know-- you
know, I ask these girls,
I'm like, you know that,
like, this lives forever.
Like, what if you want to
run for office one day?
What if you want to
go into medicine,
and there's your crotch,
living forever on the internet.
And the younger generation,
they're like, we don't care,
and we don't think
our peers care.
And you know what?
Maybe they don't.
But that's-- I don't
know what that is.
It's not fitness.
So I just-- and the look at
me, look at me, look at me,
is also not fitness.
I don't know what
the fuck it is.
It's like validate me.
And that's not what
fitness should be about.
Fitness should be about you
validating yourself, not
going and taking a
picture for 10 minutes
to find the right
angle in the mirror
so 50 people can tell
you you look good.
So that-- that stuff
freaks me out, dude.
And this is where I'm
like, God, I'm old.
But I love some of the
younger personalities
and the interesting
things they're
doing with actual
fitness and the way
they're incorporating technology
to build community for people.
And that part's really exciting.
So I think it's the continued
evolution of connectivity
and community and
accountability, as well as
having more and more
accurate information
to get better results faster.
MARY LIZ MCCURDY: Great.
Thanks.
And in terms of what we can
do about it, so where do
you see Google playing a role?
I mean, what's holding us back
from getting more people moving
and healthier?
JILLIAN MICHAELS: OK.
MARY LIZ MCCURDY: We talked
a little bit about Android
specifically, and you have
2 billion Android users that
are actively on our platform,
so we have a responsibility
to help impact their health.
Obviously, you have
100 million followers,
and are a huge influencer
in the community.
JILLIAN MICHAELS: Across
the platforms, the users.
MARY LIZ MCCURDY:
What can we do?
JILLIAN MICHAELS: The
goal, in my opinion,
is to make that information
as simple, accessible,
and effective as possible.
So, how can you give
them information
that is not overwhelming?
It's kind of like what you were
talking about today with the--
your information layout
and what you're giving them
and what you're prioritizing,
and how can you give them
information that they're
like, that I can do,
they can afford it,
they can access it,
and they will see results,
they'll feel better right away.
Or like, hey, little tips.
Hey, you know, push them
to sign up for Google Fit.
And it's like, hey,
enable this for us,
and we'll be able
to do this for you.
And I think it's just in really
encouraging, simple ways,
because ultimately
those baby steps yield
far bigger results over time.
And meeting people
where they're at.
And that's the cool thing
about what you guys can
do with that phone is that--
and all your technology is
you know where they're at.
You know where they live.
You know what their
economic status is.
You know the foods they like.
I mean, it's crazy.
So knowing that,
it could literally
be like what you
said, we noticed
you've got this great park
in your area, go-- you know,
maybe you should get out
and go for a walk today.
We've seen you've been
sitting for several hours.
And--
[LAUGHTER]
Present company accounted for.
MARY LIZ MCCURDY: Yeah.
JILLIAN MICHAELS: And I
think--I think that support,
and holding them accountable,
because they're attached
to a device or a watch or a
screen, can be really helpful.
I mean, if I was to get really--
MARY LIZ MCCURDY: Go there.
JILLIAN MICHAELS:
--Machiavellian about it,
I mean, I would definitely
manipulate the infor--
I would prioritize the
proper information.
Because there is--
I think that today--
I find younger people
read it on the web,
and they're like,
well, I read it.
I'm like, but that
doesn't make it true.
You know?
MARY LIZ MCCURDY: Yeah.
JILLIAN MICHAELS: So it's
like kind of really looking
at curating feeds on
fitness that are-- which I
know you're not supposed to do.
But, I mean, if
you're asking me--
like making sure that the shit
that's true goes to the top
of the search--
MARY LIZ MCCURDY: Yeah, yeah.
JILLIAN MICHAELS: --and the
shit that isn't, you know, like,
we want to pay for this ad about
a tapeworm when you search--
you know.
So it's crazy how many
people are manipulated.
It's like fake news.
Same-- it's the same thing.
MARY LIZ MCCURDY: Yeah.
JILLIAN MICHAELS: Fake
ads, fake this, fake that.
And if they could curate
that and kind of clean up
some of that mess, I think
that that would help.
MARY LIZ MCCURDY: Yeah,
Google's partnered
with Harvard and Mayo
Clinic to prioritize,
in the search knowledge panel--
JILLIAN MICHAELS: Really?
MARY LIZ MCCURDY:
--information on health
because of the reasons
that you mentioned.
JILLIAN MICHAELS:
I didn't know that.
Yeah.
I think will make
a big difference.
MARY LIZ MCCURDY: Awesome.
Great.
Well, those were
the questions I had.
I'd love to open it
up to the audience.
There's a mic that
we can pass around.
Don't be shy, or Jillian's
going to have you do burpees.
JILLIAN MICHAELS: Right?
[LAUGHTER]
Or it will just be
really awkward silence.
That too.
AUDIENCE: OK, this might be too
personal, but how was your--
JILLIAN MICHAELS: I got
a pap smear yesterday.
AUDIENCE: No, not that personal.
How have your
thoughts on marriage
changed since before you
decided to get married?
And do you regret waiting as
long as you did with Heidi?
JILLIAN MICHAELS: I
don't regret waiting.
I mean, in truth, the only
reason I can still see
to get married is estate tax.
I'm like, if I love
you, who gives a shit?
But, you know, for her
it means something,
and so I respect that.
You know what I mean?
But, to me, I just--
because I think I've
seen so many people,
like, get married because
they want the wedding,
or get married because
they think they should.
Excuse me.
Or get married because
of the shoulds,
not because of the wants.
And I'm like, what
are your shoulds?
Because I want to be with
you, I'll stay with you.
I don't need paper do that.
But if it does prevent
her from losing 50% again
to the government,
then yes, I'll do that.
So, you know, so be it.
But I-- you know, I
don't change that much.
I'm flexible in that the people
I love, I want to compromise,
but I'm--
you really have to show me
something unique and new
to change my mind about
things, which I know is bad,
but-- and it does happen.
But with that one,
I'm like, nah.
But I would-- I do it
because I love her.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
I'm wondering, as a parent,
how you balance, you know,
your kids and having a healthy
lifestyle, you know, not--
you know, not-- wanting to guide
them, not, you know, do this,
don't do that, letting them
make their own choices,
but helping guide them to
having a healthy lifestyle?
JILLIAN MICHAELS: Yeah.
Well, you know, what's
interesting, with my kids
I've been really
lucky because it just
hasn't been that
difficult. But if I
look at why I think it hasn't
been that difficult, in truth,
they have very
limited screen time.
I'm like, you have a
social network, outside.
Go outside.
And, you know, we have the
luxury of sending them outside.
So, you know, they're
not on screens,
and so they're really fit
because they play all day long,
I mean, except for
when they're in school.
And, you know, they're
on the jungle gym.
They're in the pool.
They're on the trampoline.
They're running around chasing
each other with water guns.
I mean, they're constantly
bouncing off the walls.
So I, honest to
God, just let them--
I mean, they don't stop
eating, and I don't stop them,
because they're crazy fit.
I thought that there
might be a time where
I was like, ugh, oh no, you
know, before having kids,
like what do you do if
they're eating too much?
But, because they're
constantly moving and growing,
that's not been an issue for me.
I do, when they want
stuff that's crap,
you know, they see other kids
having stuff that's crap--
like, they eat sugar.
They eat fat.
Like, I put organic
Cheetos in their lunch.
Luke's makes an organic Cheeto.
Like, I put that in there.
Or I'll-- you know, every
day they get a treat
in their lunch, but I'll put
like an organic peanut butter
cup from Justin's, or a little
OCHO chocolate caramel bar
that's organic,
because I'm like,
they'll burn the sugar off.
But their little bodies
cannot handle the chemicals.
Their organs aren't
even fully developed.
It's really dangerous for them.
So that part I mitigate
as much as I can,
and explain to them why.
Like with my son,
I'm like, if you
want to eat that marker, I'll
let you have that Otter Pop,
or, you know, you can
have an organic ice cream
sandwich from-- whatever.
I just discovered one the
other day that they like.
So I try to explain it to them.
And I have, quite honestly, for
the longest time-- and I also
look at people that they
admire, whether it's
Beyonce or Luke Skywalker,
and I'm like, I promise you,
Beyonce is not
eating Fruit Loops;
at least I don't think so.
[LAUGHTER]
I don't think so.
I know her trainer, and I'm
pretty sure that my girl is not
eating the Fruit Loops.
So-- and that helps.
You know?
AUDIENCE: So I think
mine's a good build
on that, because I want to ask
you the same question but about
spouses.
I don't have kids, but inspiring
your spouse to, you know,
get in shape and stay in
shape, without ever making them
feel like they need
to or et cetera.
JILLIAN MICHAELS: [EXHALES]
It depends on the spouse.
There are two strategies you
can employ to motivate someone.
The first is you
lead by example.
And, in truth, it's
really all you have.
You lead by example.
You talk about the things
that you want and perspective
on the outcome, you
know, what's the why.
If you have a why to live
for, you can tolerate the how.
What's your why?
How do you see the future?
Very innocently asking
them what their why is,
what they see for the future.
Letting them be motivated
and inspired by your journey.
Sometimes it works.
Sometimes it doesn't.
The other thing is to
just literally crack them
over the head with
fear and concern.
And sometimes it works.
Sometimes it doesn't.
And the reality is that people--
remember that whatever
the food or the behavior
is providing them, it's
something significant for them.
They may not even understand it.
You might not even
understand it.
But it has to hurt
more to continue
the way they've been living
than the work and the fear
and the loss associated with
where you want them to go.
And that's where if
they see you being like,
I'm afraid you're going
to have a heart attack
and orphan our two
kids, I really am,
and you're just in tears.
And it's not, you're an
asshole, you're lazy, it's like,
listen, I love you.
I'm really afraid.
This is a reality I
think we're facing.
And if you can hurt them enough,
make them feel-- or you're not
hurting them, but make
them feel the hurt of that,
and it's more
uncomfortable where
they are than where
they need to go,
you've got another
chance of them moving.
But sometimes that
stuff is so deep.
And I can give you one example
of what I'm talking about.
So-- I can give you
many, but here's one.
So there was a kid that I
worked with on "Biggest Loser"
for a little while, and he was
doing great, he was like 18,
he was there with his dad,
they were both doing great.
They went home for the
holidays, and they all
come back to the "Biggest Loser"
ranch, everybody's weighing in,
and it's like
everyone's doing great,
and the dad gets on the
scale, he lost nothing.
And the room gets kind of quiet.
The kid gets on the scale, and
he gained like five pounds.
They were gone for two weeks.
And everyone starts with
the bullshit of like, oh,
the traveling, and the
food at the airport,
and the whole-- they start.
And that--you know
that's not what it is.
So I'm like, listen, just tell
me what happened step by step.
So he starts with
the, I packed my lunch
and, you know, with
the surface stuff,
and I go to the airport,
and this, that, the other,
and I walk in the door, and
all my friends and family
are there, and there's my mom,
and she starts crying and not
tears of joy.
So it turns out that mom is
morbidly obese, and upon seeing
husband and son being
significantly more fit,
I mean, she immediately
shuts down, withdraws,
becomes depressed, feels like
they're going to abandon her,
like, they've outgrown her,
they've left her behind.
And so, you know, it's the
primal abandonment for him,
and what does he do?
He slams the brakes on the
weight loss and starts eating.
What does the weight afford him?
An emotional connection
with his mother.
You think you can
change that easily?
AUDIENCE: No.
JILLIAN MICHAELS: No way.
So, you've got to appreciate
that you may never
know what the answer is, or
why they're attached to it.
They may never know.
But it has nothing
to do with you.
Those two strategies may work.
They may not.
You'll hear a lot of
people say, well, I
had a massive heart attack
and then I changed my ways.
Look at Clinton.
Massive heart attack, and
then he changed his ways,
but that's what it took.
I hope that doesn't happen, but
sometimes a rock bottom moment
is necessary, and you
can't facilitate that.
MARY LIZ MCCURDY: Thanks.
I think we have time
for one last question.
JILLIAN MICHAELS: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
This is a fitness question.
JILLIAN MICHAELS:
Oh, there you are.
I was like--
AUDIENCE: Right in front of you.
JILLIAN MICHAELS:
Sorry about that.
AUDIENCE: That's OK.
So, I'm just wondering,
like, for-- you
mentioned about fitness
goals and about weight loss,
and, like, a scale
as your compass.
And it totally makes
sense, but what
about if it's, like, a little
bit more complicated, like,
if you want to lose
weight, gain muscle,
and how do you go about that
with nutrition wise, what
to eat, when and what
time, after a workout,
before a workout, and, like--
and if you're going to, like,
lose the weight, are you
going to, like, sprint 5K,
or are you just going to do
like a long-- like, you know,
just sprint just
short distances?
You know what I mean?
JILLIAN MICHAELS: OK.
AUDIENCE: So like--
I'm sorry.
I've always wanted
to ask you that.
JILLIAN MICHAELS: All right.
So, first of all, women don't
really gain muscle size.
It's really hard.
I mean, you could.
You'd have to eat a lot of
food and lift very heavy,
and really be extraordinarily
diligent about that.
We just don't have the
androgenic hormones to like--
we can maintain muscle.
We can burn intramuscular fat.
We can condition muscle.
But to like literally make
something bigger on your body
by adding muscle,
it's very hard to do.
Like, Mr. Olympia puts on
three pounds of muscle a year.
When you think, like,
God, is that all, I mean,
if you take three
pounds of hamburger meat
and slap it on your body, it's
a hell of a lot of muscle.
But, at the same
time, like, when
you put it in perspective--
because trainers
are like, oh no,
you're just--you know
what you're doing?
You're gaining muscle.
That's bullshit.
So it's not that you've offset
loss with muscle gain; that's
not true.
So you've really got to
focus on one or the other.
If you want to gain size,
which I don't think that's
what you mean.
But you can't gain and
drop at the same time.
So-- and fat does
not turn into muscle.
It's not led into gold.
So you would drop the weight and
then start putting on muscle.
With that said, if you're
like I just want to get leaner
and I want to lower my
body fat, which is what
it sounds like you want to do.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, probably.
JILLIAN MICHAELS: Condition your
muscle and lower your body fat,
it doesn't matter what you do,
as long as you're consistent.
What will get you there faster,
sure, high-intensity training
for shorter periods of time.
20 to 30 minutes,
four to five times
a week, with-- in
conjunction with being
really good about your diet,
will get you there the fastest.
And if you take a
duration-- a long duration,
low-intensity day, make it like
your off day or your recovery
day, that'll get you there.
Just take you longer
because it won't
affect your metabolism
as intensely,
or your EPOC, your afterburn.
Your elevated
metabolic rate is not
as great from lower
intensity exercise.
So, high intensity gives
you a greater burn during,
greater burn after
the workout's over.
It-- oh God-- it facilitates
improved fitness faster,
which allows-- continues to
allow for greater intensity,
and it becomes--
it gains momentum, and you work
out harder, you get fitter,
you work out--
holy shit.
Forgive me.
You work out harder,
you get more fit,
you burn more calories, and
the cycle begets itself,
if that makes sense.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
JILLIAN MICHAELS:
But there's not
going to be a
right or wrong way.
There's just going to be
a faster or slower way.
AUDIENCE: What about the eating
wise, like, what to eat and all
that, and like to--
JILLIAN MICHAELS: If you want
to-- what do you want to lose?
AUDIENCE: Like 15 pounds
or something, and also
gain the weight--
JILLIAN MICHAELS: With 15--
but I would say, you know, if
you're in that vanity pound
range, don't create more
of a calorie deficit
than 500 calories.
Because I bet if I took you
to the doctor right now,
you would-- your blood
pressure would be good,
your heart rate would be
good, your fasting glucose
would be good, your
cholesterol would be good,
and your body is like,
well, I'm perfectly healthy,
why is she starving me?
And so it would signal a
metabolic shift to slow down.
Because that's
what metabolism is.
It's biochemistry.
It's the hormone balance
of human growth hormone,
insulin, cortisol, grow and
let-- all of those things work
in a symphony, and
they are all responding
to your environments and
your food, your stress levels
and so on.
So if you are reducing
your calories too much
and you're already
fit and healthy,
your body is going to signal
metabolic slow shutdown.
So that's where with
people like you,
I'm like go to no more
than a 500-calorie deficit,
and eat clean.
So, if you're using your
little contraption that says,
hey, you burned
2000 calories today,
and you eat 1,500, that's really
kind of where you want to be.
And don't eat chemicals.
Keep it simple.
Doesn't need to be--
don't overthink it.
When you overthink it,
it's impossible to sustain.
Just because something is
simple doesn't mean it's easy,
but at least if you
can stick with it,
it's a heck of a lot more
accessible than too much
information and all of that.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
MARY LIZ MCCURDY: Thank you.
All right, well
thank you, everyone.
JILLIAN MICHAELS: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you so much, guys.
That was fun.
MARY LIZ MCCURDY:
Yay, it was so fun.